good morning everyone can everybody hear
me
oh I have one of these so not this one
does this one also work oh okay cool
excellent so I like I like using my
hands for programming presentations you
know I I don't think the the
speech-to-text is quite where it needs
to be in order to make it otherwise so I
will be speaking into this guy and if at
any point during this you can't hear
what I'm saying just like throw
something at me to get my attention
and and I'll continue so the
presentation is available at this URL
and I'm also dynamic webpage pretty much
everywhere on the internet so github
Twitter whatever if you want to at me
during it I would love it I'd love to
hear what you think good or otherwise so
let's get started all right so the title
of this talk as described by PI data is
around Kevin Bacon age detection and we
will do that but it's also going to be a
little bit more interesting I think to
look at a comparative review of three
different cloud service providers api's
and what these api's do is basically
give you deep learning functionality
with just about ten lines of code so
they're just like a simple call to a
REST API and you get back a great deal
of information about faces about ages
about emotions at times so it's really
interesting to see and I think you'll
enjoy it
so yes face detection ap is a
performance comparison and a case study
so Who am I i am paige Bailey and I do
things with computers I also work for
Microsoft I have about ten years
experience with Python and four with our
pythons my favorite though
so I'm really happy to be here
Hadoop and spark and all those nice
little all those nice Apache tools I've
been playing with for about the last two
years so we're not going to be
discussing them really today but if you
would like to talk about them afterward
I would be delighted so that's about it
and based in Austin Texas but about to
be moving to the redmond area so it'll
be closer to the Microsoft campus and
with that I hate PowerPoint so oh I
probably should have started with the
everything in this talk represents
personal views and not the pans of my
employer oh yeah so live demo alright so
if you go to that website that I that I
mentioned before
page view slash PI data NYC you'll see
three different links we'll start with
this first one so I promised you Kevin
Bacon and this is a Jupiter notebook
explaining explaining just that
so everybody's seen Jupiter notebooks
before right show of hands if you said
the keynote probably so Kevin Bacon is a
movie actor who has been around for you
know the last several decades right so
we have an extensive corpus of
photography devoted to this to this
great man
and what that means is that as we scroll
down we can see him all the way from
Footloose in 1984 through tremors
through wild things frost/nixon and
contemporary and what the cognitive
services faced api does this is a
Microsoft product it is available at a
free tier and after I believe 30,000
calls per month you have to start paying
which is which is quite a bit but what
it does is you import a bunch of
required libraries so requests and the
URL library numpy things they are all
probably familiar with you have a
subscription key that ensures that we
can that we can track your utilize
and charge you money if appropriately
you specify a region for your function
to call you specify headers and then
some request parameters and what you can
see here are there a number of options
right so we have the ability to return
an estimated age a gender a smile so
zero to one how happy he is facial hair
so different types mustache beard
sideburns head pose glasses emotion hair
makeup accessories occlusion blur
exposure noise lots and lots of
different things and what's feeding this
so Microsoft has a propriety
a deep learning framework that we've
open-sourced called CNT k so you've
probably heard of tensorflow
you've probably heard of cafe 2 and CNT
k is very similar so CNT k is what's
what's feeding this cognitive services
api you request the parameters you have
the request body you send in a jpeg and
you get back this response so for this
first picture we have for this first
picture that one we have estimated age
emotions exposure levels values for
facial hair values for glasses lots and
lots of different things and why is this
useful right why would this be something
that that you would want to be able to
use in your application structure so the
the idea of using deep learning right
you have to have engineers placed on
staff which are usually quite expensive
you have to have infrastructure so deep
learning virtual machines usually with
very high-end graphics cards you have to
have an enormous amount of data so lots
and lots of information used to train
and the the reality is that most large
companies are the only sources for those
large amounts of data so example Google
Microsoft Amazon lots and lots of
classified imagery available
whereas if you're operating out of a
start-up you probably don't have access
to that this gives you all of the deep
learning capabilities that you would
have if you had a team of data scientist
or machine learning engineers on staff
with ten lines of code and like I said
it is a proprietary sort of thing so you
do have to start paying after thirty
thousand after thirty thousand calls per
month and there are three different
service providers who currently have
them right so why would you want to use
one versus the other and if you go to
that first link what we have is a table
that I've compiled of all of the
different features that you could
incorporate into an API so custom face
detect would custom face detect is the
ability to train based on for example
you have you have pictures of all your
employees right and you want to be able
to specify okay well we have imagery
taken and meetings video documentation
tell me which one of my employees are in
this meeting or if I have video footage
of a hallway tell me which one of my
employees is walking down the hallway
and that's that kind of feels you know
slimy yet satisfying right like kind of
kind of Big Brother II but but that's
that's very very useful and again it's
just ten lines of code bounding boxes
Google has to well let's see it let's
see this kind of in action right so
we've got all of these different options
that you can have for returned returned
features and let's look at a case study
so can anybody tell me who these four
gentlemen are did any of them look
familiar and druing yep
you got so this is Yahshua Benjie oh
that's Geoffrey Hinton it's kind of the
father of deep learning and that's Yann
laocoön so these four guys when placed
through four different four different
face detection ap
this is the response that you received
back so who is played with open CV here
a few okay excellent
so open CV is not using deep learning
not at all it's an open library from
Python using something called a boosted
cascade you have a couple of options so
there's har and LTP and we'll be looking
at that later so at the end of this talk
you'll be able to do precisely this get
a face of bounding box and then also an
estimate for right eye and left eye and
what you see here are the responses that
AWS Asher and Google compute for the
same photograph right and you can see
some variation you can see that AWS has
bounding boxes that aren't placed
vertically horizontally you know sort of
perpendicularly aligned with the frame
of your with the frame of your photo and
this could cause some complications if
you have if you're using open source
libraries or if you create your own
proprietary algorithms Google Cloud has
a number of placements on faces this
would be useful for sort of the
automatic image recognition that I was
mentioning before and Microsoft does as
well so it's also important to note that
the white dots and the blue dots that
you see here are only a subset of the
points that are returned by Microsoft
and by AWS and the responses if
anybody's interested in seeing them so
this is the the JSON response that you
would get from a call to cognitive
services from Microsoft so you can see
it gives you some confidence levels and
some information about hair color and
all that good stuff so this is for this
is for the same photo from Google it
looks a little bit more like this you
can see that the bounding the bounding
polygons are actually so you have the
the XY coordinates as opposed to
Microsoft's
that are giving you kind of heights and
links instead so top left width and
height and then google also has XY and z
coordinates for every feature listed on
the face as well so left have left out
bro right afraid eyebrow all of those
good things
Microsoft has something similar but it's
only in two-dimensional space so it's
just XY coordinates but given that you
have the pitch in the yaw and the sort
of orientation of the head you would be
able to derive the Z coordinate yourself
and then Amazon again so they they're a
little bit different and we'll take a
look at this a bit later they don't give
you precise pixel coordinates just
proportions of how far it's traveled
along of how far it's traveled along a
picture so going back right why would
this be useful
if we look at the if we look at the
bounding polygons and the bounding boxes
for this photo right so this first one
pretty straightforward everyone looking
at the camera very very obvious frontal
face structure even the open-source tool
was able to pick it out so you have
bounding boxes that are very similarly
placed there there's a little bit of
confusion around placement for eyes but
we but we do seem to be able to pick
those out pretty well what about these
edge cases right so this is another for
for famous people not so much in machine
learning but just in computer science if
you can name all four I would be very
impressed but Claude Shannon is on the
left and that's John McCarthy and these
four guys are obviously not looking
straight at the camera so how do we how
did the for IP eyes work with those edge
cases and what you can see here right is
that open CV is able to detect three but
only with a bit of parameter tweaking
same for AWS a sure is able to predict
the the three on the left and then
Google is able to pick out all four and
why would this be M why would this be
important so if you if you start
thinking about profile structures for
faces right it is it is remarkable that
an open source tool would be able to to
detect this guy and not this one or if
you're using a deep learning framework
that it would not be able to detect this
guy on the left right so if we move to
the first the first notebook that I was
talking about if you wanted to roll your
own API right so the the face detection
API is that we mentioned before lots and
lots of features so smiles eyeglasses
sunglasses gender hair color as you can
see OpenCV doesn't really get
any of that it just gives the the face
placement and also the eye placement
that the cost structures aren't
necessarily prohibitive right like if
you were if you're going to hire a
machine learning engineer on staff to
create and support an application you
would probably be out a little bit more
than twelve thousand to $16,000 a month
but if you did want to try to create
your own and you would probably want to
because it's fun this is how you would
go about doing it so this this Python
notebook explains how to use open CV to
extract facial images from these guys so
we've got the same photo right and using
open CV first what we do is we have to
convert this from a BG our color space
to an RGB color space and what does that
mean so when you use open CV it
automatically converts the picture into
a different a different format because
it's a little bit easier for the
algorithm to understand the hard
Cascades classifier or the LBP in order
to use in order to display to matplotlib
with true color we have to change it to
a different different color space for
our first pass using hard Cascades we're
going to try with the eye detection and
the face detection right and it works
out fairly well so we've got the the
bounding box is placed but only two
different two different eye locations
this is using just the overall eye
cascade and not the right and left
specifically so if we want to get a
little bit more detailed you could use
the particular right and the left eye
XML file from OpenCV and that gives us
the detail that we saw before
right so you would have the right eye
located there the left eye related there
and there's some duplication for
Geoffrey Hinton and for and ruing but
for the most part you're still getting
appropriate placements
and if you wanted to do parameter
tweaking right so the thing that we did
before listed in this function if we
wanted to stress test it with the the
image that's not full frontal faces then
we would have to go about parameter
tweaking our scale factors right so it
was 1.1 this time if I switch it to 1.0
to 5 and it takes a little bit to Train
then we would be able to pick out the 3
but that's the highest performance that
we would be able to get for this
particular picture if you wanted to try
a different algorithm so local binary
pattern as opposed to our cascades this
is this is what you would do and the the
highest performance that you can get is
still just the two central figures as
opposed to as opposed to all for the
hard Cascades profile classifier also
only picks out Weizenbaum on the right
so these AP is the level of detail that
they're able to show I'm is only
possible through deep learning right so
if you if you wanted to if you wanted to
create your own your own algorithm for
face detection it would be quite simple
if you wanted to do it for something a
little bit more nuanced so the the
propensity for eyeglasses or sunglasses
gender hair color whether or not someone
has I or lip makeup those sorts of
things you would you would probably
either need to use a deep learning
framework or you would need to use one
of the proprietary api's so for the
Kevin Bacon age detection right why
we're here today what we found after
executing each one of the each one of
the pictures is that the classifier is a
little bit biased so scrolling down
towards the bottom you can see that the
actual age estimate so 26 30 to 40 50 59
differ substantially towards the edge
cases for the actual age right and why
would this be and it would probably be
because of overfitting when you have a
training data set for deep learning it's
only able to give you it's only able to
give you information about the data that
you feed it and the feeding the data set
that's been fed into the algorithms for
CNT k4 tensorflow
for for any sort of deep learning
framework they're they're mostly focused
on you know ages 20 through 40 because
who's building these things they're
programmers right and what are their age
demographics they're mostly 23 40 so as
you get out to especially younger ages
or upper ages you're probably going to
have you're probably going to have
different
it's the same for it's the same for
movie actors right so why would this
potentially be biased for Kevin Bacon
maybe he's had some facial
reconstruction done maybe these photos
have been retouched in Photoshop so so
the accuracy of the ages vary based on
based on input based on situation and
then based especially on your training
data if we go back to the comparative
performance of the of the api's so I
mentioned a perk of Google right Google
gives you XYZ coordinates that can also
be derived through pitch and yaw XY
coordinates that are available through
Microsoft and also from Amazon
what about ages and what about emotions
so age estimates for this guy kind of
elderly gentleman on the left a little
bit younger on the right if you look if
you look at the actual ages in April
1968 at Fred khun's 34 so he's the guy
that's very obviously smiling Claude
Shannon's 52 McCarthy's 41 and wise
mom's 45 Amazon and Microsoft are the
only two api's that offer age detection
and the accuracy of each is kind of
displayed over here so what what this is
doing is it's taking the JSON response
that you saw in vs code so the the face
details with the bounding boxes the age
ranges for Amazon and then for Microsoft
the the age ranges that you see down
here so I believe it's up towards the
top
and it's pulling in it's pulling in a
confidence interval and if you're
familiar with statistics I'm assuming
this is this is kind of like a 95%
confidence interval for the actual age
estimation from Amazon but the spread is
huge right so you have a you have a
variation of like 20 plus years for each
estimate which isn't really telling you
much at all the cognitive Services
estimation doesn't give you doesn't give
you a confidence level but it does give
you at least kind of a floating a
floating value for what it assumes the
age to be and like I said Google Google
doesn't really offer that in terms of in
terms of placement for certain features
it offers quite a bit but for for age
ranges and for emotions not so much so
happiness right or it or any sort of
emotion detection how happy would you
say this guy is I would be at you know
smiling seems to be smiling seems to be
pretty joyful and for the face API
attributes it seems to be pretty pretty
confident that happiness is a thing
Google returns very likely very unlikely
very unlikely very unlikely very likely
for the different for the four different
emotion options Amazon recognition has
three options so confused
disgusted and also happy so those are
the only three options and it doesn't
seem to be very clear right so it's 52
to 62 percent confident that this that
this gentleman right here is disgusted
and confused so not not quite the the
different emotions that microsoft offers
or again anger contempt disgust fear
happiness neutral sadness and surprise
which is pretty extensive there's also
the option to pick out whether a person
is wearing eyeglasses versus sunglasses
versus goggles so some sort of sporting
equipment
there's the ability to detect sideburns
or actual actual eared or a mustache and
the ability to also it detect certain
accessories like hats that's listed up
in the table listed up on the table here
you can you can see that in like I said
in terms of the accessories the emotions
sort of the the people information the
things that make a person tick Google
Google's not quite as capable AWS is
also a little bit a little bit behind
and the the shorthand here is comp
stands for confidence interval
percentage is is kind of giving you a
percentage value as opposed to a float
and then X just means that it's it's
available and then the final cells down
here are related to facial landmarks and
orientation all of the facial landmarks
seem to be placed in about the same area
for the ones that are present Google and
Microsoft give you precise pixel
locations whereas Amazon just gives you
a zero to one value on how many pixels
it's traveled across the photo and this
shows you how you would go about
creating the z-coordinate for pitch in
yaw for pitch yaw and XY if you have the
if you have the others and then you know
everybody's always concerned about costs
right so AWS is listed in blue here the
grey is is cognitive services and then
the orange is Google's is Google's API
so that that is all I have
has everybody been following along does
anyone have questions about open CV or
about about any of the api's that we've
seen here today the rest api calls are
all very very similar to the one that
you saw here for cognitive services
right so you're just importing libraries
you're defining a subscription key and a
URL to to base your region you have
headers with specific parameters and
then you you just end up executing the
API calling getting back the JSON
response yes the most common customers
for this guy so the full extent of api's
right so cognitive services the full
extent of api's is everything from
vision to speech to text sentiment
analysis to search to language so we
have about 35 listed if you if you would
think about use cases for this right so
snapchat you know the filters where you
have the weird dog ears and the nose and
the sort of smiley faces that can be
masked you can create that app very
simply using this cognitive services API
or any of the others that I mentioned
right because you would be able to
detect automatically where pupils are
located where mouths are located that
would be kind of a fun use case there's
also obviously the the feature that I
mentioned before right so if you're able
to detect a specific human being then
obviously that would have a lot of a lot
of customers in government and military
and even you know sort of business
settings it also would be kind of a
nifty extension to LinkedIn right like
if you are able to walk around in some
sort of an augmented reality situation
and detect oh well that that guy Joe
is the vice-president of whatever
company I should probably go and talk to
him about something that sort of thing
so that would be very useful as well or
detecting if someone was falling asleep
at the wheel right so detecting a sort
of I gaze about paying attention there
there is also a use case that I heard of
where some movies what they do is they
send laptops with films pre-loaded to
potential customers the customers then
watch the movie and and I sort of give
feedback back to the company on their
opinions but what this would do was it
would be able to detect that it was just
that single person watching it so not
anybody else
it would also be able to detect
attention spans and emotions as they
watch the film so you would be able to
see in real-time tracking whether or not
a person was disgusted or happy or angry
their precise emotional response to that
particular extensive media so that would
be useful as well yes facematch yes so
that's what I mentioned before um
unfortunately Microsoft is maybe
fortunately Microsoft's the only the
only API that offers that OpenCV does
give you the ability to get this give
you the ability to do sort of eigen face
matching but you would have to provide
your own data set and train it the what
you would do the way that it's
structured in code is you would have a
directory with a number of pictures five
to 100 however accurate you wanted it to
be of a particular person and then you
would just kind of point the API towards
that folder and be like okay well if you
see anybody that looks like Paige in any
of these photographs tag it as page and
out-of-the-box cognitive services and
Google's vision API are able to detect
celebrities so if you stick in a picture
of Natalie Portman it's able to detect
that it's not only Portman or if you
stick in a picture of Kevin Bacon it
detects that it's Kevin Bacon and again
the entire motivation is kind of giving
you all of the tools for a deep learning
task without you having to learn
tensorflow or learn CNC K yes so so you
have to train it on your own data if you
want it to do like a corpus of your
employees if it is just the if it is
just celebrity so things that the
internet would know then then you don't
have to train it at all yeah yes yes so
so sometimes they are but mostly in
terms of detecting minors right so
another use case would be say you have a
website that you don't want a
thirteen-year-old to to be accessing you
want to make sure that the person is
adults you know 18 plus it would be
useful to have you know your video
camera take a picture of that person's
face to detect their age for a given
threshold and then and then use that to
say okay well you have access to this
site now so so I would say that like if
you're looking for extremely high
accuracy probably not if you're looking
for a general estimate of whether this
person is young versus college age
versus you know thirties to forties
versus elderly then then it would be
useful for you
yes so if you if you give me usage keys
I would absolutely do that like it's but
and it's the same for it for anything
IBM cloud or any of the others
the only reason I was able to do these
these estimates that are listed in the
table here is because I the free tier
for Google and for AWS an open CV is
often obviously also free tier they do
all right
I put clarify I will add to the list but
in general like I said before each one
of these guys has different has
strengths and weaknesses Google's give
you gives you XYZ coordinates out of the
box but you can always derive your own
it's also the best at spotting faces
that are more in profile though Claude
Shannon was detected by Microsoft and
Google both in terms of emotions and age
that would be probably Microsoft
bringing up the head and then also the
ability to detect things like beards or
mustaches or sideburns or different
sorts of accessories AWS has a little
bit of walking us in terms of in terms
of sort of pixel placement like it would
be it would be very difficult to to sort
of incorporate that IP I with with
multiple others and then it also doesn't
have as extensible to listing for the
particular feature landmark locations so
that's why you get for for the amount of
money that you would pay for it that
that is that is what you get and free
tier for the different for the different
tools varies Google is it gives you
several thousand per month I believe or
maybe one thousand
AWS is 5,000 calls per month this is
30,000 per month and OpenCV is obviously
very free so excellent and then I also
wanted to mention a note on deep
learning in general right so so the
three the three api's that I mentioned
they all incorporate some sort of deep
learning so CNT k versus tensorflow
versus whatever AWS is using but the
reality is is that it's very very easy
to fool a deep Learning Network right so
what you see here is an example from
clever honza's blog if you're interested
in adversarial machine learning at all I
sincerely recommend looking at it um
what this is is so does everybody agree
this look like so panda it's pretty
panda like looks like it lives in a tree
and it eats bamboo tensorflow is fifty
seven point seven percent confident that
this is a panda but this image is is
that if you introduce point seven
percent noise so just 0.7 percent of
data added added to that picture what
you get back is an estimate that this is
a given with ninety nine point three
percent confidence a similar feature
would be that you probably saw that
thing floating around hacker news
recently where a turtle was mistaken as
a gun it's the same the same general
idea if you deep learning deep learning
networks are so very easy to fool and
it's mostly because they've they've been
kind of hyper fit on these particular
parameters with their back propagation
there's also a recent paper done for one
pixel attacks for fooling deep learning
networks and this is this is an estimate
of how these these guys were
misclassified so this is an airplane
that was misclassified as a dog which
jumps one pixel of noise added I'm a dog
that was miss classified as a ship all
sorts of things
and so if you're architecting your own
deep learning systems I sincerely
recommend I sincerely recommend
considering how this sort of bad actor
activity could could harm your deep
learning models because if they're if
they're misclassifying that would that
would be potentially hazardous rightly
if your if your company is in the
business of detecting where missile
locations are in satellite imagery and a
bad actor is able to introduce point
seven percent noise that suddenly
classifies it as a place that's that's
safe then that would be a bad time so
you will over fit there are five stages
brief I suggest you look at them and
that is all so thank you
[Applause]